the fire swept through the top floors of
this four-story Factory nestled in the
heart of a West End residential area
residents say hundreds of people lived
and worked here making plastic bags and
bottles 23-year old Simon was lucky to
escape with her family we were asleep
when we heard people shouting about the
fire we saw people from the second floor
running down we were asleep on the first
almost everyone ran out only those who
were fast asleep died or were injured
there were small children on the first
floor and we managed to get them all out
but the fire was so terrible on the
second and third floor that we could not
reach it the fire was really bad
struggling to reach those trapped inside
the building because of the narrow and
crowded streets emergency workers were
forced to carry the injured two
ambulances waiting nearby there are
hundreds of factories like these which
employ thousands of people illegally
running in residential areas now this is
like a tinderbox waiting for a tragedy
of this sort to happen it took 25 fire
trucks and over a hundred and fifty men
to put the blaze out desperate and
distraught relatives could only wait
outside the hospital to identify the
dead most of those working here were
laborers from the state of Bihar in the
north-east of india
Bergman's had it they put all those who
were taken out from the building on fire
in an ambulance and bought them here we
were about 30 people from my village
affected in this incident but have only
been able to see some of them
an investigation into the fire is now
under way but tragedies like these have
become all too frequent as the focus now
turns to safety standards in the
nation's capital
never Lazarus Sky News Delhi